Alright. So what do you think?
>> I think the answer is, three. It sometimes
would be left and sometimes would be right, depending upon
where you randomly start. So for example if you
start with your random centers on a and b. Then
I think what'll happen is, d will end up
on the right, as that point gets dragged over towards
the weight of the right, it'll drag d with it.
If you started out with both points on f and
g, then I think d would get dragged to the
left cluster as the left most cluster got dragged to the
left. I think if you started it with a and
g, then it would depend upon how you break ties. And
since I always break ties lexiographically, because I like saying
the word lexiographically, it would end up on the left. So
I think the answer has to be the third choice. But,
I'll say one thing, I wish it were the fourth choice.
>> I would like to grant this wish by talking about the
next clustering algorithm which, in particular,
does soft clustering. And, soft clustering
allows for the possibility that a point can be shared you know,
I'm a little bit of this, I'm a little bit of that.
I'm a little bit of country, I'm a little bit of rock and roll.